brahim burqa est le gérant d'un fast
food à mantes la jolie à l'étoile de fès
depuis son ouverture il ya quatre ans le
maître mot est la solidarité récemment
face à la détresse des étudiants le
restaurateur a décidé d'agir davantage
ça nous d'être solidaire entre luttes se
serrer les coudes et comme j'ai dit les
étudiants à cesser une culture de la
france si l'on n'aime pas se poser la
question qu'est ce qui doit manger
toi tu te dis dans ta tête tu as envie
de devenir avocat mais l'état ils
demandent d'aller faire la queue pendant
une heure dans le froid pour avoir des
pâtes et du beurre c'est juste
inconcevable en fait pour obtenir un
repas rien de plus simple il suffit
juste de venir et d'indiquer que l'on
souhaite manger la personne dans le
besoin pourra donc choisir entre un
tacot une viande ou un menu
cheeseburgers on vient on dit je veux je
suis étudiant je veux manger au lieu
d'un amant je ne me pose pas plus de
questions que ça on va pas leur montée
de demander un dossier pour un prêt
bancaire
s'ils viennent et récupérera moi j'ai
repartent avec le sourire
s'ils veulent venir deux fois par jour
une fois par jour pendant je sais pas
jusqu'à ce que la situation s'arrange en
fait il n'y a pas de problème nous on
est là pour ça chez brembo cas cette
générosité étaient déjà présentes
il a mis en place dans son restaurant le
principe des tice dengue a suspendu vous
prenez un menu vous payez un cheese ou
de houe autant que vous voulez en plus
nous les honorons les notes dans un
carnet et fois qu'on arrive à 30,50 yvon
l'apel l'association avant qu'il fasse
une parodie ni prévient la veille et on
les prépare tout simplement les emballe
les meilleurs dessins cachot il voulait
distribuer sur paris la semaine dernière
avec le grand froid le restaurateur a
permis de distribuer 190 zingueur à
paris d'un point de vue religieux
culturel et grâce à son éducation
cette solidarité lui semblait naturel on
a grandi dans un quartier défavorisé
qu'on sortait à l'école en sortie
scolaire quand il était petit pas vers
sandwich à la catalane complète il
n'avait pas été obligée partager avec
lui tu avais un paquet de chips il ne
l'avait pas tu lui donnes c'est comme ça
toi quand tu avais pas aussi en avait d
autres types donné on a grandi dans
cette ambiance-là son action était
largement saluée sur les réseaux sociaux
mais aussi par les clients réguliers
je pense que c'est une bonne initiative
et on en a besoin en les temps qui
courent et ça fait du bien aussi de voir
que ça existe dans nos dans nos
quartiers dans nos villes et que ce soit
des étudiants ou des personnes en
difficulté on en a besoin et ça fait du
bien
aujourd'hui brin burqa espère que
d'autres restaurateurs prendront le
relais de son initiative partout en
france